here with reaction from the trump
organization eric trump is with us
okay your dad he's out there it's not
like they're going to give joe hard
questions when he did the couple of
press conferences like
oh it's um i go who do i go next to
david it from nbc i i mean
something's odd okay how do you become
president
when you won't talk when you won't show
up when you won't take questions
where you don't get hard questions
well sean the bar is so low i mean i was
in wisconsin all day yesterday i
traveled through the whole state by the
way the enthusiasm there is absolutely
incredible
my father was there the day before the
vice president's there today
but it's been 660 days since biden's
been in wisconsin
now you're supposed to have the the dnc
in milwaukee i think you remember that
it's been 660 days since he's been there
and no one asks a question
why hasn't biden showed up right the
same thing with michigan and the same
thing
with all these i mean the media sets the
bar so low if my father didn't go to a
battleground state for 660 days
oh my god sean they'd be they'd be on
top of him they would go
they'd be going crazy he didn't even
show up in the state that the dnc was
supposed to be at he hasn't been there
for
two plus years and everybody gives him a
pass he has taken it for granted they've
set the bar
so low i mean all he has to do is live
through the interview to
the speech tomorrow i mean so long as
he's still living at the end of the
thing they're gonna you know applaud it
as being you know the greatest piece of
uh
you know lingual art uh you know that's
ever had it's crazy the bar is so low
and it's disgusting
and bar is low now in a way and i'm i i
would bet everything i had
that he's been practicing practicing
practicing look at what the poll that i
talked about earlier here
there are more americans a majority
nearly half of democrats believe that
biden will not
finish a four-year term i mean that is
stunning look
for all the questions the mob and the
media asked about reagan
in 1984 joe biden will be
older his first day of office than
reagan was on his last day of office
well i think that's why they encouraged
a radical to run with him you look at
kamala harris you look at our stances
you did a beautiful job covering the
opening but
you know getting rid of all private
health insurance i mean 180 million
people that's over half the people in
the country would lose
private health insurance plans i mean
you know you know
free health care for every illegal
immigrant defunding police i mean think
about the notion of defunding police
they tried to do that in new york i mean
they defunded some they got rid of all
undercover police officers in new york
and crime went up by 250 percent
in three months it doesn't work but the
point that you're making sean is exactly
right
right they wanted somebody who is an
absolute left-wing radical
because honestly even if joe biden was
in office you think he's actually
going to be running government i mean
the guy called arizona city last week he
said he was running for
senate you know senator of the united
states no he's running for
commander-in-chief and arizona's a great
state but you really think this guy has
the aptitude to run government she's
going to be the one that's running
government i mean come on let's call a
spade a spade
let's look at kamala harris um she has a
more leftist socialist record in the u.s
senate in 2019 than bolshevik bernie
himself no private health care
she feels that it's the right of a
president to just bypass the legislative
branch government take away people's
second amendment rights by executive
fiat
that's pretty radical she will eliminate
fracking she sponsored the radical new
green deal
in the u.s senate that's 94 trillion
dollars i don't think you need to
graduate from harvard or mit
to figure out when you only take in four
and a half trillion dollars a year
that uh the 94 uh in 10 years will
bankrupt the country
how is ending fracking and eliminating
all fossil fuels
how's that going to fly in pennsylvania
and in wisconsin and in ohio
uh and and midwestern states where your
dad
did bring the jobs back that biden and
obama's that weren't coming back
but by the way the fact that we're
fracking is a reason we also have two
dollar gasoline at the pump right now
it's it's a reason it costs a little
to heat our homes on a relative basis
versus seven years ago because my father
made this country
energy independent but one other thing
about kamala harris said that no one's
bringing up but i don't know why
she's from san francisco beautiful city
unfortunately it's gone to absolute hell
sean i mean
you look at the crime in that city you
look at the homelessness in that city
you know you walk down the street
there's people defecating you know in in
the streets you walk your kid to school
and you're white walking over hypodermic
needles and this is a city that she
governed over so
you know if you want the rest of the
country if you want these states if you
want you know all these swing states and
the rest of the country
to emulate san francisco and the
policies i mean people can't even live
there the taxes are so high and
you know again the city's gone to total
hell you know if you want then then she
then she's the perfect uh running mate
for you i mean
the the problem with the dnc is their
tone deaf to these issues they're tone
deaf to what their party stands for and
how radical it is and how disconnected
it is
hey might work in york city sean and it
might work in los angeles
but it doesn't work in the other states
and they lose a lot of people and
i think you see that in terms of the
lineup that they uh they have out there
tonight
all right she applauded la's decision to
defund the police by 150
million dollars by the way i no private
no choice i thought liberals were
pro-choice no
no option for public for your own
private health care plan
wow sponsoring the green new deal as i
said
okay now joe said please become the
enemy and he supports reallocating funds
okay are these people they're not
talking about the
the the lack of law and order and safety
and security and all these liberal
cities that have been run by liberal
democrats for
decades yeah yeah well it's true i mean
go to florida incredibly safe go to
georgia incredibly safe go to the
carolinas incredibly safe go to uh
texas incredibly safe then all of a
sudden you go to
democratic strongholds right go to
portland seattle minneapolis chicago and
now
you know new york city and look at the
difference between these states there's
one common denominator in all those
states guess what they're run by
radical radical leftists both mayors
and governors their policies don't work
i mean we've seen the case studies they
don't work we've seen this movie we know
how this movie ends
we just saw it over the last three
months in new york they strip out a
thousand
undercover nypd officers and guess what
crime goes up by 300 percent sean this
isn't a difficult thing to figure out
and
i don't know why they continue to double
down on it this is not a winning issue
for them i mean
stripping private health care is not a
winning issue this is not a winning
issue getting rid of the second
amendment
not a winning issue coming after
people's religion not a winning issue i
mean
i don't get it i don't i don't get why
this is a policy but then you see the
speakers that are lined up including
elizabeth warren and i'm so glad you
mentioned that she was at the
native american roundtable at the dnc
yesterday i mean
these people are tone deaf sean they
really are to true america they don't
they don't get this country they don't
get what america stands for and that's
why my father is going to beat these
guys in 73 days
well 76 but who's counting i never i
don't keep track of dave it's close
enough though
but certainly closer than their
estimates for the cost of the new green
deal eric trump thank you